cette marche blanche on va en voir
d'autres images ce que de son côté le
rassemblement national alors qui n'a pas
participé à la manifestation à tenue
marquer une minute de silence verrez ça
dans un instant mais on a d'autres
images qui vont arriver de de cette de
cette marche vous qui
autour de la table est-ce que vous êtes
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de dire
ça il y a plein de gens qui disent que
c'est de la récupération politique cette
marche qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
Géraldine moi la marge de cas organisé
aux Zemmour je la trouve immonde en
revanche moi je récupère en fait moi je
comprends qu'on récupère ce drame à
titre personnel comme citoyenne je
comprends que à force de dire il faut
pas récupérer en fait c'est à force de
dire ça quand on a un sentiment
aujourd'hui de l'axisme d'impunité de
voilà d'exaspération et d'insécurité
donc si ce drame absolument immonde
les politiques s'en emparent enfin pour
faire quelque chose et pour faire
avancer les choses ben moi ça ne me
dérange pas ça ne me choque pas en fait
ça veut dire que quand même il y a une
démarche d'aller à Limpy et autres pour
déposer le marque vous imaginez allez
déposer une marque au nom de cet enfant
qui n'est même pas encore enterré
sur la tête celui qui fait on te celui
qui l'achète aussi hein si c'est par
hasard
comme Béatrice moi j'aurais pas fait la
marche parce que la famille avait bien
demandé que il voulait pas que les
hommes politiques s'en emparent ils
voulaient pas que tout le monde s'en
empare comme ça j'ai j'ai honte de tous
ces politiques qui s'en vont en parler
il me foutent la honte parce que c'est
c'est pas des pères de famille ils vont
se rendre indiquer après moi je suis un
père de famille respectable non quand tu
récupères une affaire comme ça tous ceux
qu'on lance les hashtags j'ai appris
qu'il y avait des parties qui avaient
fait qui avait racheté des noms de
domaine c'est à vomir le parti qui a
racheté le nom de domaine là c'est à
vomir pour moi ces mecs là on fait quoi
c'est c'est rien fait tu aurais dit les
hommes politiques ne font rien écoute
moi bien écoute-moi bien moi il m'arrive
un drame comme ça et j'apprends qu'un
parti politique c'est raconté
mon fils il faut avoir reconquête
comment je vais aller les voir moi c'est
c'est pas des trucs à faire ça c'est un
manque de respect total et même je vais
même un peu pour je vais même un petit
peu plus loin je déborde un peu il est à
la famille il y avait demandé qu'on les
laisse tranquille et j'ai vu des chaînes
info allez dans le Pas-de-Calais pour
les traquer pour traquer les voisins
ceci cela ça aussi les mecs
détendez-vous un peu et comme tu dis on
peut pas comprendre la douleur de cette
famille parce qu'on a on a personne avec
qui ça mais est-ce que vous vendez un
drame de ce qu'on voit des dessous de
verre c'est coussins des noms
des des des des sacs à corbeau non mais
je vois ça vendu immonde sur les réseaux
non mais ça là et on voit des gens qui
sont interdits sur les réseaux et et on
enlève leur compte pour des voilà ce qui
donne leur avis sur quelque chose et que
c'est un avis qui qui voilà non mais qui
plaît pas tous là vous vous rendez
compte de ça et ce compte il est
toujours voilà vous pouvez aller acheter
ces produits dérivés mais ça mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils font c'est non pour moi
je m'en fous d'être légal ou pas les
gars la morale c'est pas ça le légal je
vous le dis ça c'est ça c'est c'est
inadmissible normalement les les mecs
des réseaux ils doivent enlever ça je
suis désolé ça c'est inadmissible ça de
vendre ça des coussins des dessous de
verre non mais c'est n'importe quoi et
de laisser ça sur les réseaux non mais
on est où là on marche sur la tête oui
mais bien sûr que le business de fin
c'est le business de l'obsen et du du
pire c'est c'est juste à gerber et ça je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord et c'est
horrible mais on a le droit aussi enfin
on a le droit en fait c'est un tel
martyr c'est aujourd'hui un tel symbole
qu'on a le droit quand même de se poser
des questions aussi politiques par
rapport à certaines choses à certaines
héritiers ben oui c'est autre chose mais
je pense qu'on peut aussi je sais pas
marcher sans que ce soit récupéré
politiquement en fait
si la Marche Blanche organisée plus tard
pour respecter le temps du deuil mais
après c'est compliqué c'est quoi le
temps du deuil comment peut-on se
remettre d'une telle horreur c'est quoi
le temps du deuil donc moi je pense que
pardon en règle générale les marchés
blanches sont organisées par les
familles exactement en main et ils en
ont besoin parce que ça leur fait du
bien parce que ils sentent qu'il y a
autour d'eux comme une sorte de cordon
sanitaire de gens qui leur disent vous
seul et on pense à vous donc tu te sens
pas concerné quand tu sais par exemple
qu'elle devait quitter le territoire et
qu'elle était sur le territoire c'est
autre chose moi j'ai envie de me poser
la question enfin vous poserez sans
doute la question
pourquoi aujourd'hui les gens ne sont
pas renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
pourquoi il y a 120000 au qtf et il y en
a il y a 1800 places ensemble de
rétention et pourquoi il y a 20 % des
gens qui sont dégagés il y a une
impuissance de l'État ils vont te dire
qu'on peut pas parce que les pays
veulent pas
tout à l'heure il sera là on dirait
juste